hey everyone welcome to led live we're
so glad that you're with us this week
and we have our guest
jason and we're gonna talk about can god
reach you anywhere find out on this
episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness everyone we want
to welcome you to led live thank you for
joining us
this week of course we said we had jason
and he used to be
a mormon now you're not a mormon anymore
we also want to thank our patrons for
making the show possible
you guys sponsor us you help us put
these shows out every week
and so if you're not a patron you don't
know what that is check it out in the
link below and you can see all the
little perks you get
for being a patron uh we send those
people
an exclusive t-shirt now only at a
certain level so you gotta be 15
a month but you get an exclusive
producer's t-shirt and
you'll notice that a couple of these
guys they're wearing t-shirts scotty's
got a shirt monkey's got a shirt we make
our own shirts i'm not wearing one today
but jason's wearing one
michelle's wearing one i'm the odd one
out i probably look more like the mormon
today
that's okay so check out our t-shirts
check out our stickers we've got
stickers scotty's got him on his water
ball
water bottle and we've got all kinds of
ways that you can help support our
ministry
and of course watching our videos
sharing them
those are great and helpful and please
pray for us because
we are doing battle you might say every
day we get all kinds of
questions all kinds of testimonies we're
giving people guidance
writing emails answering people's
struggles through social media
and we just want to help people so pray
for us that god will give us wisdom
to do that so we want to talk to jason
today
jason you were in the mormon church at
some point
some of that didn't make sense anymore
and you said decided to go a different
direction so what happened where did
that take you
what did god do with your life sure let
me
back up just a little bit um there was a
number of things that happened in my
childhood that had a major impact on
shaping
me some of them good some of them bad
i mean growing up in the church i was
your typical good mormon kid i went to
church every single week i went to
classes i did all the right things
you know i didn't drink the coffee and
tea and i followed some of those things
most of the time
um so then i did the thing where you get
baptized at eight years old but shortly
after that
um when i was in my late ninth
nine years old ten years old and on i
started having some
how can we say encounters and some
challenges that i
i didn't ever think was possible it was
something i found is very normal now but
very terrifying the first time it
happened i remember i was sitting in my
room
and i had going to bed and i remember
feeling like it just got really really
really cold like you walked into a
freezer box
and it it scared me and i was like
something's wrong something's really
really wrong and it felt
like for anybody that hasn't felt it if
you've been there you know what it's
like but it's just like
evil like a blanket of evil i don't know
how to describe it perfectly but i woke
up
just kind of scared and i remember
getting up and i ran to the door and it
just spun
and so i ran to the other door because i
had two doors out of my room and it also
spun and i remember turning around and i
looked up
and there was something there that i
couldn't tell what was it wasn't clear
but it was evil that's about what i
could say and i remember
falling down feeling like i couldn't
move and it was like crushing me like
crippling
force pressuring down on me and i i
could see my breath and i'm just
shaking and i thought for sure i was
going to die
and i remember sitting there on the
ground thinking i'm going to die what am
i going to do
and the only thing i could think of was
save me jesus
i didn't really know what to think i
didn't know what to do i hadn't really
been prepared
for this by the church i grew up in but
i for whatever reason it flashed in my
mind
peter saying save me jesus when he got
and walked out on the water so i thought
save me jesus i remember it like lifting
like a cloud
and i ran to my dad my mom's room woke
them up they thought i was crazy
they were like you know go back to bed
you had a bad dream and i'm like no no
no i'm not going in there unless you're
going with me maybe you have kids
that had something like how old are you
at this stage maybe nine ten years old
and so this presence of evil there i
remember going back in and the curtains
were
going down against the window and my dad
noticed it when he opened the door and
he looked at me and he looked at the
windows
and i remember thinking that's weird he
went over and he checked the window a
little bit he went to bed
he said all right go to bed and i
remember i went to bed and
when i woke up my dad was checking him
and i found out later that there were
double pane windows that were sealed
shut with no wind able to come in around
there was no way to open them
and so whatever was there was exiting
and so
this was kind of some of the beginnings
of my spiritual encounters
and so i became a believer in not just
good spiritual things but
evil and sometimes we can say we don't
believe in one or the other but
they are both very real in my experience
and
it wasn't long after that i began to
have even more
problems in my life but i would
just pause to say god wherever you're at
whatever you've done god will call us
out of darkness
into his marvelous light and he who has
begun a good work in you will complete
it you become a new creation
and that's the beauty of no matter how
dark the past is no matter what you've
done there's always hope in jesus
and so um as i was kind of going through
life i
i broke my arms a lot like nine times
skinned off my ears cracked my head open
lots of terrible things i was an
accident prone kid but those weren't
really that big of a deal to me i still
got plates and screws in my arm
here
[Music]
and you can go all the way in there here
and if you want to fill the heads of the
screws you probably can if you push
that's just weird you're like that
you're like the bionic man
i used to scare the kids that there was
an alien in there
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no what happened so my family is an
interesting family so one of the things
that happens growing up in
a religious home that was very
conservative but very
focused on externals um legalistic is
what it often comes
out out as there's a lot of rebellion so
i got to the point where i rebelled but
prior to that i had all these older
siblings i mentioned i was the youngest
of 10
and so a number of my siblings had kind
of gone away and got into
drugs i got into alcohol got into many
things
and the one in particular that was
really bad
i have one brother and he is a dear
brother he's cleaned up his act i love
him to death
but uh he wasn't much older than me and
he really got messed up
he got really involved in math so if you
have anybody out there anybody that's
experienced it
it's pretty ugly stuff if there's one
drug that i believe the devil has
created
it's that one i mean out of all the
drugs that one will bend your mind the
fastest
and i mean you just see people's lives
ruined many people don't come home from
that one
yeah it's pretty bad on one episode so
my brother
sadly to say and i mean i can tell you
about it here my brother
doesn't remember any of it he was so
high on math that um coming back and
i've tried talking to him only once or
twice but he just feels guilty
um have you ever it's like a bad dream
and so it doesn't seem real even part of
my past feels a bit like a bad dream
because i
it's like talking about yourself in the
second person because that's
that person died and now i'm a new
creation in christ so when i
think about it it's pretty bad but i
mean at one point
i remember i walked into his bedroom he
had a friend that was probably also a
drug dealer that was in there
and he had a pistol on the glock sitting
on the bed
i was like can i see it he said and and
i reached over he goes whoa whoa
he took the bullet out of the chamber
took the clip out and said just a sec
and so i was looking at it
and he put the bullet back in the clip
and my brother walked in he starts
getting angry
he's like what are you doing why are you
touching that you shouldn't be having
that and
so much so that he started yelling at me
and he started he's chasing me around
the house so our house had a full circle
you could go around
so i made the full second lap and i
remember stopping in the room
and i looked over and the gun was still
sitting there the bullets were
there but he'd put the clip back in and
my brother says
i'll teach you click
pointed it right at my head and i
remember hearing that click
and thinking of my dad
you know because it was so terrifying
and so i had the demons
of drugs that were kind of haunting me
at that point so there was more than one
time my brother tried to kill me
at one point his friends thought it
would be fun to make me snort a little
meth when i was
maybe 11 or 12 years old and handcuffed
me to a door
so i had some pretty horrible
experiences
it was not easy it was just these things
were going on around me and even when my
my brother went to jail a couple times
when he got out of jail
uh we had an intelligent attorney that
got it ruled so that they could
have a sign to where they could come and
search the house but they could only
search his room
rather an invasive over the whole home
so my brother started cooking meth in my
bedroom oh wow
so uh you know we had just so many
things and he
he would get all tweaked out and he
would go in and i remember he he poured
a transmission fluid in my brake fluid
line and it dissolved the brake lines
uh nearly died driving back down into
town one day
about 60 miles an hour headed into a
major intersection and
i don't know how i didn't die so he
accidentally did this or
i don't think he meant to i don't know
just kind of you're tweaking
he was tweaked out and paranoid and
doing just
crazy stuff all the time and it got so
bad
i mean i i went places with him when his
driver's license was taken away by the
time i was 16 i was driving him around
and i i guess part of me like when i was
in those teenage years
i i started getting associated with the
drug life
even though i wasn't in it i don't know
if you've ever been unfairly
put in a camp that you didn't belong in
um kind of thing and so
i was trying to be good yet my brother
was doing all these things so i was
getting associated with it in high
school
in everything i did and so at one point
i remember
just being like you know what's the
point
um i lost my best friend recently that
kind of tied me in with the mormon
church a little bit more and i'd started
drinking
smoking a little bit started going
downhill but i figured
look if i'm going to get labeled a
druggie i might as well do it right wow
and i remember making that conscious
decision because
um to just back up a little bit before
that
this all came in a falling out away from
the mormon church
so right prior to when i started really
getting into drugs is when i
i don't know if you ever felt like
you're just a sinner and there's nothing
you can do
and you're just broken and god could
never forgive you so i
i had a lot of these thoughts smoking
and drinking all these things because i
just
was like man i know i shouldn't do this
i mean i know what the scriptures say to
some extent
at least i know that's bad and i saw the
things that happened when i did it were
bad
and so i went to my bishop and i'm like
hey man i'm i'm doing all these things
and we had recently moved out of the
town we lived in just like 20 minutes
out of town and i was like one the only
one in my household even going to church
right then
my mom had stopped attending my dad
didn't often attend and so here i am
just going on my own
as like a 16 year old kid that takes a
lot of nerve to do that against your
parents
but because i was making those mistakes
i'm like this is what i'm doing and when
he
he basically turned me away and said i
was a bad kid in a bad influence
wow i made that mistake that i allowed a
person
in a church to turn me away from god so
you you labeled that
church identifying it with that person
as a kid how do you not identify
church and god as something similar well
it's kind of a two yeah it's kind of a
two-fold message because i believe we
have
a responsibility in how we treat to be
the
and so little things that we say
comments i mean correct me if i'm wrong
but wasn't marilyn manson involved in
christianity at one point in time and it
was literally someone at his youth
pastor
yeah he went to a christian school and
his first attempt to really like
fit in or communicate or whatever the
first thing that he ever saw that made
him actually believe in god was a
picture that his grandmother took out of
an airplane window
and it literally looked like jesus or an
angel or something in the clouds
to him this was like wow this makes me
believe in it
so he took it to i think it was a
catholic school he took it to show and
tell
and when he showed it what he was proud
of they said this is
blasphemy get this out of here and and
from that point on it scarred him
and he just like went anti-christ
completely yeah i mean you don't realize
what one
simple word can do and turn someone away
you know so you're a pastor yeah
do you have people come to you and you
they have that similar kind of
experience where it says deep
dark stuff and it's like they're afraid
to tell you and what's your response
going to be
and very much so um i've had people that
were literally
abducted and trafficked heroin addicts
you name it with pain and hurt in
today's day and age
everybody's hurting and i think
something for me at least i find
although i
i'm not i don't like what i went through
in some ways and the things i did
but it has shaped me to where i can
understand where people are coming from
and i know how it feels to be on the
other end of that and so it makes me
i would hope a more compassionate person
because it's true so many people are
hurting and just because you can't see
it
just because you don't know about it
doesn't make it invalid
right and so for me at that time i was
really hurting
and to be pushed away to me that was god
pushing me away and you know it's
natural but i i found you know that
there's mean people in every church
i really believe that you can go to
basically any church it wouldn't matter
whether it was christian or not
christian you can find a mean person
and so we can't let one encounter with
one person that
didn't follow god give us our definition
of what god's like
and so i think it's important that we
let scripture kind of show us who god is
as the clearest revelation in jesus of
what god's like
but it's really a call to to church
members people like listen
there there is kids that you have no
idea what's going on under the hood
right
i mean it's just like their world is
falling apart they're ready to commit
suicide you never know
and one wrong word can just crash their
whole world down
and make them completely reject it so i
mean as as a church man we should be a
open arms type people like kids should
want to come in and just be like
man i feel i feel great here like i feel
like i belong and they want me to belong
have you ever left a church or wanted to
leave a church because of something
somebody said to you
no i almost walked
oh wow how about you yeah i mean yeah i
did walk but
i've had it happen since too about you i
i grew up a believer but left because i
saw the hypocrisy of the believers you
know but did somebody like say
something to you specifically that made
you like i'm checked out i'm going home
or they were
so but i was judging the church by the
people you know what about you michelle
no i came this close i was gonna walk
and and
i think that's i have you know when we
go out and speak i remember
i did a conference or not a conference
conferences speaking engagement in
connecticut last year
and these young men came to me
afterwards and they were talking about
how they all had a pornography addiction
i was like
it kind of took me back for a second
because i was like well that's really
bold to just come out and admit that
but it was helpful to them to talk about
it and
and be real with everybody and be like
look we got a problem
do you have any resources that you would
recommend for us so that we can
you know overcome this and they were
kind of a support group to themselves
you know to encourage and uplift and all
that
and but you know the adverse reaction
could have been like wow you guys are
terrible human beings you know you got a
porn addiction like
you know you should leave i really think
it should be like that too often times
we go to church we
put on a fake smile you know you're
stressed you're getting ready and then
you walk in that hey everybody
how are things oh great you know but
that should be the one place
that we should be like this really
should be able to be real
yeah can you pray for me like i've been
dealing with this well i've i've
actually had people
do this to me um i walked into the
church that i go to
and um you know i'm friendly just saying
hi to people and
and this i walked up to this one guy um
who usually teaches a a little school
and um i said hey man how's it going and
he was just like not good
and i was like oh yeah what's wrong is
that man pray for me my marriage is just
falling apart
and and you know it's kind of like
caught off guard because it's not like
what you expect people to say and then i
was just like
what do i say you know and i was like oh
well i'm not going through the road i'll
pray for you and stuff like this but he
totally caught me off guard because
i'm not used to people coming and
responding like that right
yeah it's a trick because i think people
are wanting to they value
authenticity real be real stop putting
on a
fake face like you have it all together
we
we get so much fake news and so much
garbage out there we just want something
real and so sometimes the realness can
overwhelm people like you say and
sometimes it can
not being prepared people can say things
that seem judgmental
and i've had that i'm guessing you
experienced some of that and you know
when you have that judgment rather than
grace
both are real there is judgment but
there is grace in knowing which one to
do when
and how to go about it is a bit of an
art and you've got to be led by the
spirit to do that
um i think it's important that anybody
in it that wants to be a christian
has to be letting god lead them in how
to do that
you know we're all sinners we've got to
recognize we're all sinners in need of
grace the first step in getting help
is admitting you've got a problem yeah
you've got to shine light on it yep
because
sin thrives in darkness and unless you
put a light on it
a little light that's white out of
darkness into the light
so he shines a spotlight on it but then
it makes you come to the lord
so yeah um with me once i
disassociated myself with god the church
i felt abandoned
quite honestly that that's really what
it felt like like there's nobody there
for me
i can't trust my family can't trust my
brother sometimes you know with this
stuff going on
and i i just like was like okay
let's see what the world's got and so i
just went all
out hardcore um to the point where
i mean just to give you a glimpse of
where it went
at 17 years old i moved out of the house
dropped out of high school was just in a
full-blown party
home to where they got raided by the
swat team wow
that's serious so yeah so
they literally busted in with the
shields and shotguns and the whole nine
yards and it was like
yeah i think i need to make some
different decisions
this is not really working the way i
thought it was getting high was one
thing but
you know it was just it was ruining my
life
and it's amazing how many of us it's
like when
we don't feel like we're full of joy we
want personal fulfillment somehow and so
we seek it
outside of scripture and we don't look
at who god sees us to be but we look at
who others see us to be
and then we fail and so
i mean for me it was quite a journey
in conversion mine wasn't necessarily a
saw
type knocked off my high horse type
thing
i have elements of that but i don't
think that's what everybody experiences
yeah i find some of the people that come
to me and struggle they're like
hey i grew up in the church but i don't
feel converted
yeah what does that mean converted does
that mean i have to go sin
to be able to be saved right and it's
like well i want that cool testimony
like you do and so
some ways i'm timid even right now
sharing the story because when i
i don't want to i don't want to glorify
in any way how bad i was
to make an analogy because i i run into
this too
where people they want that cool
testimony it's like if you don't have a
messed up cool testimony then
people are like i don't know if i want
to listen to that guy or not you know
but really to make the analogy it's like
the difference between
giving yourself away before marriage and
staying a virgin
right you know if you if you think about
like if i could keep my
life as pure as possible by christ's
strength and grace
that's a beautiful testament yeah it's a
beautiful story right
i remember a friend of mine he said the
best testimony i have is that i don't
have a testimony
he says the fact that god protected me
from all that is way better
than having to go through it that's true
so he might use it
to my advantage but the pain and the
scars and the things i did to other
people
that's still there because let's be
honest everybody i've been there
like you not probably maybe to the
extent that you have
it's maybe fun in the beginning like
it was fun for the first few but when
you are crawling in the ditches
trying to get high scraping through life
just literally like feeding after it
that is not fun
that is not living and and many people
get to this place where it's like
you don't even want to exist anymore
you're just like this is this is not
life this is not enjoyment this is not
fulfilling
at all and so those people that actually
don't have that testimony i guarantee
you they've had more
joyous fun days probably than even what
you look on the outside and you say oh
wow you must have had fun
no that wasn't fun that was like like
being in hell
you know and and coming out of that is
is
a miracle it really is i mean i've seen
others do it and it's just pretty
remarkable
the depth of a trench you can dig
yourself into
the rabbit hole nobody's ever seen the
bottom i mean it just keeps going and
going
yeah it's nice i mean i i got to the
point as many addicts do where you steal
from your parents anybody you can
anything to get the next fix so and i
i i bought into that lie initially that
er marijuana is not a gateway drug
that's what they told you
so i'm just gonna smoke some pot get
stoned and go
you know and just go brain dead and
watch tv um and
that sounded like fun but it didn't stay
that way
it just it seems like for me at least it
was always trying to get stronger it
went from smoking a
marble to smoking a camel wide to
breaking the filters off to smoke them
it's just like oh yeah i know it makes
me want to vomit just thinking about it
right now but
you know i just always had to push it
further and further
and i remember the devil just hates it
when you try and get out
i remember getting the point shortly
after they raided my house
the swat team did i had been pulled over
so many times by undercover
narcotic cops because they were really
after my brother
um and i had 36
charges i believe it was on my juvenile
record
so yes i i messed up pretty good um and
so
i had really ruined my life and i
remember when they
raided our house we got out and i
remember they walked me out and they
said
where's your brother and i was like what
do you mean where's my brother
and they they just kind of looked at me
and i'm like i'm not telling you where
he is
and i knew where he was and i hated him
because he tried to kill me he messed up
my life but i just didn't feel like that
was something i could do and they said
look we'll wipe your record clean
give us the big fish you're just a small
fry kind of thing and so
i remember being tempted but i decided
look no i need to get myself
out of this if i stay here i'm going to
die in this i watched at one point
um someone listening might know what it
is but it's
i watch my brother do a hot rail so you
heat up the glass really hot and then
you snort the mouth and it
smokes as it goes up and in and he did
so much of it that he
fell on the ground flopped like a fish
and stopped breathing
right in front of my eyes and they drug
him out of the room
people started screaming i'm like i just
watched my brother die
he came out of it um but i remember
thinking
that this is my future yeah i mean when
you get into meth is such a dark drug
because it just takes over everything
and it's so addictive
so you got to the point where you're
like i'm fine with getting busted
because it's going to get me out of this
even if i get out of jail yeah
i i if i go to jail it didn't matter to
me at that point it's like i just need
something to make it stop and quite
frankly i didn't feel
i had the power in me wow because i
think a lot of addicts
um if they're going to be very honest
they they do
get in the trenches and they're like
this sucks i want
out of this i don't want to be here
anymore but they do not have
any ability to pull themselves out and
that's where
i made a conscious decision that i had
to remove myself from all my influences
all the people around me that were
dragging me down i had to make a break
from so a friend said hey i'm going to
go to college in phoenix you want to go
with me and i'm like
okay so i went and took a ged before i
graduated i
would have graduated high school and
enrolled in college so it looks on paper
like i was smart like i got out of
college high school early and started
college
and i tell you i thought okay a clean
cut i might
smoke still i might drink occasionally
but i'm never going back to all the
drugs
and i remember moving there to phoenix
and i'm like okay i'm going to be a good
person now
i'm going to try and be a better person
i'm going to work through these things
and
i remember i hadn't hardly been there
very long and i saw this guy at a gas
station he says hey can i get a ride
and i said sure why not not a wise thing
to do in a big city
especially the look of him i should have
told me more than it did
i gave him a ride and he says hey how
would i pay you in this joint
it was crack oh wow whoa so
i went from bad to worse really fast
um so i mean it's amazing just how i
just kept getting pulled back down and
honestly i wondered at times whether i
should just commit suicide
and i think that's how some people get
there just so desperate it's like
whether it's heroin whether it's crack
whether it's cocaine
whatever drug of choice it is you just
get so addicted that it seems hopeless
man
it really feels like there's no way i
can physically do it and the reality is
you can't
personally by yourself do it
i mean you can relate scotty through
christ all things are possible but
that's right
through christ all things are possible
you see this is when it all started to
change was when i was living there in
phoenix
i met this really cute girl
she's my wife give a little disclaimer
earlier she literally showed up on my
doorstep
people always ask how we meet she was
mad
at a friend and left with someone she
shouldn't have left with to come to my
apartment
he knocked on the door and then ran back
down the stairs and left her on my
doorstep
i opened the door and i'm like hi and
he said let her in i'll be back and so i
let my wife in and she um
she wasn't the wife at the time she
wasn't the wife at the time
but she was this backslidden christian i
i had this background in mormonism and
we we hit it off um did you know who she
was
didn't have any idea who she was the guy
who ever met her she had a scar like
this on her arm so we joked that we were
disconnected
wow um did you know who the guy was that
said i didn't know him he was
acquaintance not a very good one but
um yeah she just kind of goes three a.m
guys
that lots of people blocking us but he
kind of knew you enough
to say he'll let you in or whatever yeah
and so
i i met my wife that was kind of the
beginning of it and
i remember when we started dating we
decided to go back to utah
um i was gonna go visit my family and we
were there and so right before we
we're gonna leave the next day to drive
back to phoenix
they had this big party for me and i
took some acid and
i think she took some rooms and we were
i started having a bad trip
um those that are listening um you know
what that is
i hope you never have to learn if you
don't know what it is
really bad and the next day we're
driving back we
stop at a gas station outside of vegas
gas up drive down the road we're smoking
pot on the way there
kind of thing and we get pulled over and
my buddy gets arrested and they said
they're taking him to jail
i've already lost my driver's license
for driving under the influence of
marijuana
and so my wife has to drive and i
wondered
when it all happened when it went down
they took him and they let me go
and i remember thinking i don't this is
a new dynamic
i'm usually the one getting thrown
behind bars as well kind of thing
and they let me go and it came to find
out after we left the jail that
um with my friend there and leaving in
his car
that she'd taken a pregnancy test that
was positive
and so i found out doing that kind of
lifestyle led to other things too
and i decided very quickly for me that
was kind of part of my wake-up call
i do not want a child going and doing
what i did
how old are you at this time 17 17
17 18 years old i might have been 18.
18. but they yeah we started dating when
i was 17 i guess it would have been 18
when that happened
i was young they let you go and you're
in this they let me go if she was
driving on shrooms uh no that was the
night before so we're
we're clear we're stoned but better than
that
not driven enough so and i remember
realizing going i got to do something
different and it was like well we both
were raised with morals but it was like
okay now what
and so this was the first time she told
me about her church
first time she told me about her church
i was like those are some weird people
i don't want to go there i don't want
anything to do with them and
i was not very excited but i'm like okay
whatever i don't want to go back to the
mormon church
so that much i did know she did make me
go once just to break through
that and i remember feeling like
okay well what am i going to do about
all this stuff i can't go to a church
living the life i'm still living and i
remember
very specifically praying going okay god
you've got to do this seriously because
i can't
not capable and i remember very clearly
because i
i had smoked a whole carton of
cigarettes over the weekend
on a camping trip and then i was like
i'm having this prayer thing and i feel
sick
and i said you got to take the taste
away yeah
and the next thing the next morning
there's like habits you wake up you
drink your coffee you smoke your
cigarette
it tasted like vomit i mean i was so
nauseous at the first puff of it that
i'm like
and i literally started accusing people
of what did you do to my cigarettes
because my taste changed now i don't
want to discredit someone that's prayed
for god to
change them and they didn't have this
experience but for me
this was like the beginning of it and it
wasn't like the battle was over
yeah the struggle still came the
addiction was still there it took time
but as i continued to try and let god in
i began to see change i i started going
to some meetings
and i started to experience a joy that i
didn't even know was possible
because it was different than religion
is that fair religiosity and just being
religious
that didn't bring me the joy yeah it
just felt like rules
to be honest i mean and the rules
weren't bad i believed in the rules but
it was all rules and i didn't experience
the joy
i mean there's a difference between a
joyful christian and
a grumpy christian that's just like
critical and just nasty and
i met a bunch of them because some of
them told me i was going to hell and my
family was going to hell
i've met some mean people i've been
turned away from a church because i
simply had children
wow wow and in fact it's the current
church i belong to did that at one point
they turned me away because i had kids
because they didn't want noise in the
sanctuary so
i met mean people um but for me
it changed when i began to see a picture
of god
and one of the things i found as i was
starting to study the bible
it was different than what i'd grown up
with totally different so i was learning
all this
for from scratch and i remember reading
kids children's story books
because i didn't know what the pastor
was talking about i don't know who
gideon was
who's gideon i didn't even know who
samson was i barely knew who anybody was
in the scripture so i started reading
through those
and i started getting this picture of a
loving god
and as i began to see that i don't know
how else to describe
it but he woos this with his cords of
love as scripture puts it
he starts bringing us in to show us that
man i got something so much better it's
exceedingly abundantly beyond all use
that ass think or even imagine
the scripture puts it it's so much
better
and i started experiencing this joy but
i was like yeah i still don't want to go
to that church
i didn't want to go to my church that i
grew up in i didn't want to go to my
wife church and i'm like
what do i do so i did something a little
strange some people might ask but
i tried to prove scripture wrong hmm
a lot of people come to jesus with that
yeah right that's what sealed the deal
case for christ it ended up leading me
to become a pastor because i i remember
meeting people
still in this searching phase and where
young unmarried having kids doing all
these things wrong and they're like
you should be a pastor and i was like
you're crazy
i mean there's no way i could ever be a
pastor but
i just i wanted to find out who god was
and i didn't think
this was right because i had had these
seeds of doubt that oh this you can't
trust this it's inconsistent it's this
it's that and i mean this is what the
world tells you
and i mean the mormon church told me
that so
you know there's a lot of sources
telling you you can't trust this
but as i studied it i'm like man that
just makes sense
i mean it just seems pretty plain there
i mean a loving god would do that why
i mean where did we come from if we have
a creator didn't he create us with a
plan in mind
i mean i started to study these things
and i studied my way
into the church i'm in and i remember
just it was still hard though because
even when i was convicted of everything
the fear of leaving my family
i mean that's something i can't quite
imagine you know what i mean like
like my whole family like i guess is
believers and you know it's like to to
think that i would just like
leave that all behind and go to
something else yes
it's an interesting thought to me it was
really hard
um i i struggled with it it took me
years to work through some of the
different beliefs
but as i as i did that i remember
thinking
now what i know what i
should do i know i should be baptized i
know i should make a commitment but i'm
like
i i don't know if i can do that the cost
was too high and
it's it's just you know we get these
parables of you know you sell everything
you have to buy the pearl of great price
buried in the field kind of thing
and it was like yeah that's great in
theory
a nice spot that's a great sermon
analogy i i
get you jesus but really leave your
father mother brother
for my sake really and i remember
really just struggling with it and so i
did something a little different
in that by then we'd had our second
child and we were getting ready to have
her dedicated in the church we had a
little service for it and
you know i was also graduating i was the
first to graduate with a bachelor's in
business
and so i'm graduating i invite my family
to come to the graduation
so they come to town graduation is
friday
uh early afternoon we go to this
graduation
and you know the that weekend we go to
church
and i say hey do you guys want to come
we're going to have my daughter
dedicated they're like oh yeah we'll go
support you
i didn't tell them i was getting
baptized in the same service
so i tricked my family into coming to my
baptism and then moved to california the
next day hoping i didn't have to talk to
him for a long day
like literally the next day i was out
wow because i was like you know i i was
had so much anxiety and this is where
like peter says cast all your cares or
anxieties upon me
um this is what i had to do i had to
give it to god and to say okay
let the chips fall where they may but
ultimately
i'm the decision maker for my own life
here i can either give my life to christ
or i can say no well there really isn't
a whole lot of in-between
you can say well i'll give them a little
bit over here and i'll just do
everything over here i want and that's
how some christians try to live their
lives and it's miserable
right yeah a foot in the world and the
foot in the church makes for a miserable
christian
makes me think of the lukewarm you know
he said yeah that's the same you're hot
or cold
but because your luke hormone vomit you
out of my mouth yeah
that's that's how revelation describes
because god's like man just stop
because when we do a little bit of each
what it does is it it's
it's disrepute to god because when you
say you're a christian
and you take on his name in vain and
live like the world
and you're no different than everybody
else that's your god
you don't have allegiance to either one
no you know you're not you don't have
your allegiance completely to the world
you don't have your allegiance
completely to god your allegiance is to
yourself
yeah well this is why jesus said no man
can have two masters you either serve
god or mammon worldliness and so you
you will end up loving one and hating
the other you know you can't do
both and in my scenario
it was either i was going to give into
the world and go back
which i knew i didn't want to do or i
needed just to give it all to god
and i mean he helped me overcome all
those addictions
and one of the things i've done in my
life as i i mean continue to face
challenges i've
gone to the mission field gone into
ministry all these different things is
i have to look back and remember look
what you brought me through god
amen and you know this is something you
see in the old testament as you read the
old testament when god was
preparing a people and bringing them out
of egypt
out of slavery through the waters
through the wilderness
they were setting up memorial stones and
they were setting up altars
to remember what god has done here
and i have to go back and remember what
god has done in the past
to see my future because the reality is
is god's done great
things but does that mean i'm free of
challenges no absolutely not
i mean nobody is and so when we face
challenges for me
it's like yeah but look what god did
i mean i went unemployed and got fired
from my religion
one one point four times in one year
i moved back to utah bad call no longer
being a mormon
um so everywhere i got hired at the
church that i belonged to wrote a
letterhead
you know the pastor that baptized me
wrote a a letter of recommendation
because i want to
make it clear this is who i am now you
might know my whole family here and my
name in this town but
i'm not that anymore but to them
everywhere so part of the mormon
structure and i didn't really talk about
in the last thing
that bishops aren't paid so the pastor's
equivalent isn't typically paid and so
you have this
thing where they put business owners and
doctors and dentists and these type of
people are often bishops
and so everywhere i was going in a
financial field my boss was a bishop
so they would hire me like oh cool a
project we're going to reconvert them
and you could tell very quickly that
that was their attitude
and it was within about three months
every time that
people would ask me so why did you leave
and
i was very open the first time they
asked and by about the third time i'm
like dude don't ask if you don't want to
know
i have good reason and if i tell you
i knew my demise was within a month
because what happened is my offices
would polarize and they would
fire me and then not pay me and during
that time
the first time i lost a job was months
after i closed on my first home
wow and it was like i lost my job and
i'm like okay
now what and so the number of things i
mean i literally had an irs agent call
me
scared me half to death i thought that
world was going to end because i was
already broke and wondering what to do
and they gave me a refund from three or
four years previous
they said you'd you one of the paperwork
pieces of paper wasn't filed in i had
money
three thousand dollars show up in my
account when i went to the bank and
asked them
where'd this money come from i don't
wanna the money's gonna auto go out of
my account and i don't wanna be
overdrawn and
run into all this trouble and they said
well we don't know it was a cash deposit
there's nothing we can do and i said
okay cash deposit that's great where
what branch who did this
and they said well that's what's weird
there's no teller listed
and i go wait wait so no teller accepted
cash
but you're telling me they're like yeah
we we can't do anything about it
i mean my aunt gave me a coffee grinder
that fell that had
gold coins in it i mean
all these things that god just provided
for me
because i was faithful and so when i
when i chose to give to him i mean
those challenges will keep coming but
we've got to remember that
he is that same god we got to remember
what he's done
and mark even the little things so for
me
going a day or two days without a
cigarette was a big deal initially
going a day or two without drugs was a
big deal but as i
recognize that god's helping me with
this and remember he's made it he's
helped me through the last two days yeah
i'm tempted really bad today but he's
helped me
let's not blow this god's got this god
when we are weak he is strong and he can
do it through us
i think that some of the temptation to
when we get ourselves in trouble and
then we just want god to fix it
it's like i think we're more um more
concerned about the
consequences of our actions than we are
actually changing you know what i mean
like god is not interested in just
taking it away from you otherwise why
wouldn't he just take take take take
from everybody
he's wanting to walk you through those
experiences he wants you to walk away
from there
not ever looking back and and so you
know like
a lot of times you know drug addicts and
other people will give up on god because
they're like
i've been praying i've been praying you
haven't just taken it away from me yeah
right
are you really praying that the
consequences are are are
are taken away or are you really praying
that god transforms your heart because
those are two totally different
that's right yeah you've got to let god
see we work from the outside
in many times we try to clean up the
outside god works from the inside out
when you really let god in your heart
when as ezekiel 36
26 and 27 i will take out the heart of
stone and give you a heart of flesh
i will put my spirit within you and
cause you to keep my statues and
judgments
when god does that then you can
you can keep the commandments and you
can follow god because you love him
if you love me and that that passage in
john where says if you love me you will
keep the commandments it really should
say
you will be keeping my commandments it's
a it's an indicative it's it's showing
that it's a sign of what happens when
you love god because if you love god
you do it naturally because you loved
him yeah if you don't love him and you
just want to use them like a coin
machine and get your candy out and you
know
let me put in my prayers okay you didn't
give me what i wanted that's not how it
works
it's a relationship dynamic i'm
identifying a lot with what you're
saying like the freedom from addiction
and all that
like yeah god's not a thief he's not
taking away things that you're
cherishing in any kind of way
so you were at a point where you were
like make me hate these things because i
don't want them anymore but you gotta
you have to do it right you have to do
it i can't
but i gave him my will i want you to
change my will my desire and so
that was the only way i could see out of
it um
and also you know that that experience
of of
you know giving it and surrendering it
all to god isn't like
an overnight thing all of a sudden like
life is peachy i i i don't want this
anymore i mean i can remember
when god you know brought me out of the
whole drug world and everything
i mean there was days that i laid there
in bed sweating
thinking about what would i do if i saw
it again
this went on for years actually and i
remember
not trusting myself probably a year or
two after
was the last time that i had done it and
and just thinking that
you know i'm i'm too weak but like a
muscle
you work out enough times every single
day you get stronger and you get
stronger right
god strengthens that walk to the point
where now if you put it in front of me
you know what i mean i know where that
world's gonna go
i would not be tempted with that but you
know sometimes it
it takes us a long time to get into
those messes and it takes us a long time
to get out of those messes as well and
you have to be patient waiting on the
lord
grab his hand hold on to his his dress
and just say
listen i will not let you go until you
bless me and
resolve this in my life well and even
like the apostle paul
struggled with himself
he would say you know what i want to do
i i don't do and what i don't want to do
that's what i do and i
he had this the thing is we're we are
carnal as scripture put us
we we are we want things we don't want
our fallen
world is constantly at us but
to be tempted isn't to sin yeah and so
god always makes these ways of escape as
scripture puts that he will make a wave
and escape from every temptation so you
just gotta
fight through it you just gotta fight
through it you gotta every time you're
tempted for me
that was like the giant flag to say get
on your knees and pray
yeah because i can't win this i mean if
you're gonna try and take on the enemy
on your own you'll lose that's right you
got to have a much bigger
bigger god in your behind you backing
you and helping you and guiding you
through it is the only way i see
possible and you're right it does take
time
so you have to acknowledge and celebrate
all the little things and just say you
know okay
and even if you fall i love how the
proverb is but it says a wicked man
falls but the the
the righteous man falls and keeps
getting yeah
the difference between a person that's
just a flat out
you know broken person kind of thing
versus the righteous person isn't that
they're perfect all the time
part of it is they just keep getting
back up and keep giving back to god
and so we keep giving it to god and as
we keep giving it to god he continues to
refine us reshape us into his image
that is positive
that's so good though because i i talk
to a lot of people who
you know they're on the right path and
then they hit me back up and they're
like man
i fell and that's the same stuff i'm
telling them i'm like you know
that's that's what's awesome about god's
mercy and grace is
when we confess and he is faithful and
just to forgive us our sins
he will pick you back up and you get
back on straight arrow don't stay down
that's
that's what's wrong is to stay down you
know we will all
stumble on occasion but to stay down is
where it's
it's for me it's not letting my guilt
define me
yeah guilt and shame have a way of
making us think we can't go to god yeah
when you fall it's like you know you
just want to hide you're ashamed
and that shame and that guilt if it
prevents you from going to god
you're in trouble yeah so you've got to
break the shame and guilt cycles when
you sin
okay you sinned acknowledge it recognize
it and go to the source of help
amen is the only way to get through that
and so i i just find i'm constantly
going to him and this is
this is the process of sanctification to
use the big word whereas god is making
you more like him day in
day out and it says keep getting up keep
trusting him
day at a time i choose jesus every day
amen and if i choose jesus every day
then
look let let the chips fall where they
may i'm trusting him
if life's hard okay if life's easy
great i'm okay with whatever comes and i
i've learned that
when i try and push my own way i always
regret it and when i let god do it
it might be hard it might not be easy
but i i will never regret it
amen so it's letting him lead amen
it's pretty neat dude that you uh have
had this testimony and then now
um god is just using you in a mighty and
powerful way so
you know to see somebody who had such a
destructive path
and then you know probably the most
unlikely candidate for you to
shepherd a flock um is really anything
but that's a that's a testament to god
saying listen i can change anyone
there's nobody too far gone and and even
when we see people like you know you
you see that kid come into church and
you know
or the girl she's wearing a skirt you
know too high you gotta like talk to her
like this
you know and you know she's just looks
like a basket case right
god may turn that person's life around
and
use them for a a beautiful way
yeah he wants to and so you know we as a
church member
we have to rally around this and and
cultivate
an environment that that really helps
foster
these kind of transformations and you
know whether offering
um job programs and things that that are
in this vein i mean more kids struggle
with this drug
issue than anything else i mean you know
what i mean like there's three three or
so i don't know about you guys but
there's three people sitting at this
table that really had an experience with
that
and this is a common thing and we're not
talking about it
it's very rare that you hear churches
really addressing
these deep-seated issues and it's like
kids just think i'm just experimenting
and having fun
and then all of a sudden you go three or
four years down the road
they're not having fun anymore they're
they're not in you know a solid job
they're in
you know broken relationships maybe
children outside of wedlock you name it
and it's like we we need to talk about
these issues we need to say this is this
is real what can we do with this
so i appreciate hearing your testimony
on this because
you know i'm sure a lot more people out
there even struggle with this kind of
stuff
and just know you can give it to god god
can transform
your heart and you can be sitting here
preaching out of the word of
god literally you know what i mean like
well and to touch on the preaching thing
i mean yes we
i came out of mormonism yes i came out
of drugs but preaching
i was terrified of public speaking so i
almost didn't graduate from college
because of public speaking
and i tell my congregation look if you
get up here and you just get so scared
that you pass out
that happened to me the first series of
meetings i did on the third day
hit the ground passed out because i was
so nervous about speaking in front of
people
so one of the things i found is don't
start putting barriers where
god you can't do this right really with
god
all things are possible let god lead you
and use use your gifts and talents and
create new gifts and talents in you
why i think god uses people like this
that don't necessarily want to be here
is because you can't take the credit
that's right you can't be like well i
was already an outgoing cool
personality that you know whatever and
so i'm the one that caused this
it's like he uses people that are like
oh my goodness like that guy would be
the last person i'd see
you know go up there and do this because
literally god is saying listen it's
through my power
and my um transformation that this is
even possible
yeah the first time they interviewed me
to be a pastor they said what's your
greatest weakness i'm like oh hands down
preaching
and then they all kind of laughed and
looked at me and they said do you know
what job you're applying for
and i'm like it's going to make me
completely dependent on him
because i can't do this i can't do this
it's it's way beyond me and so
i guess that's him using the broken and
little things of the world to
bring light because i i think it's a
dangerous thing when we begin to trust
in ourselves we have to let our all our
trust
everything come through god because he's
the one that does it that's a good
answer you're hired
i did get hired
that's awesome wow well thank you
for sharing jason that's a crazy story
and you know all of us can identify with
that on different levels i'm sure
there's some people that are watching
you can identify with some parts of this
story you know the reality is humanity
is
a group a large group of broken people
broken relationships failure after
failure
we all have things inside of us that
we're dealing with we don't like to
talk about it with other people we've
seen dark places
but the good news is there's hope god
can take
anybody from wherever they're at and he
can transform them
into something beautiful and that's what
he wants to do for you so we thank you
for watching
we encourage you to share this episode
with somebody that
they've been in a dark spot they need
hope and they need to see god working in
their lives
this can show them what god can do for
them not just what he's done for jason
so
encourage you to share it don't forget
to like comment
subscribe and you'll be notified when
the next video comes out
we just want to thank you guys for
watching and god bless we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you